il est un peu plus de 18h à nancy jérôme
espions gérant du restaurant l'arrosoir
se dépêche ensuite on range vite voilà
c'est le premier jour du couvre-feu à 18
heures s'est fait un peu bizarre c'est
la place la place stan ces vidéos en un
quart d'heure c'est c'est impressionnant
la place stanislas
d'habitude très fréquentée n'est plus
occupé que par certains en c1
un peu en retard j'ai entendu qu'il
serait un petit peu indulgent pour le
week end
donc je pense que je suis à cinq minutes
de chez moi donc je pense que ça va
aller
au total 15 départements sont concernés
ces millions de français ne peuvent donc
plus sortir de chez eux sans attestation
de 18h à 6h du matin leur taux
d'incidence leur nombre de cas sur cent
mille habitants étant supérieur à 250 un
durcissement des mesures qui peut
ralentir l'épidémie selon le porte
parole du gouvernement
ce que nous disent les scientifiques
c'est que le couvre-feu fonctionne celui
qui avait été mis en place avant le 2è
confinement au mois d'octobre a eu des
effets importants
quand vous mettez en place un couvre-feu
vous limitez les interactions sociales
que l'on peut avoir dans un cercle privé
et on sait que c'est par là que le virus
se diffuse le plus en avançant à 18h par
définition vous limiter encore plus ces
rencontres mais pour les commerçants
cette avancée du couvre-feu est un
nouveau coup porté un secteur déjà
meurtrie par la crise de 17 heures à 19
heures les gens quittent le travail
et forcément il ya une perte re ya une
perte de chiffre qui se fait pour nous
c'est en termes de chiffre d'affaires
très impactant sachant que c'est l'heure
du goûter
et c'est là que les personnes viennent
le plus acheté chez nous comme nous
sommes une pâtisserie
un autre chiffre d'affaires était de 85%
de 17h à 19h voilà donc aujourd'hui on
sait on est restaurateur mais on se
débrouillait à vendre du vin chaud du
jus de pomme chaud des bretzels on
faisait comme on pouvait donc maintenant
nous pénalise encore donc on va essayer
de trouver des nouvelles solutions pour
s'ouvrir plus tôt on va essayer encore
les attestations elles restent les mêmes
tout comme la menthe forfaitaire de 135
euros en cas de non respect des mesures
un nouveau point sur l'avancée de
l'épidémie sera fait ce jeudi 7 janvier